and it sometimes gets a little bit it
gets a little tough right that's a thing
- it's like these players who have so
much passion sometimes their soul into
each and every battle especially when
you guys are close friend like this and
both representing the exact same country
same continent
these are actually two of the youngest
players you Toto I believe leave but
these are just also two of the youngest
players in the in in this bracket in
general right only that I do have to
mention that earlier you specifically
talked about the fact that link [ __ ]
had a three-peat of his own at one point
blue God was the one who stopped that at
MCR I believe it was and then we courts
got his revenge I think the showdown he
actually won that was 31 in a row oh
yeah a showdown okay sorry my brother
but blue God was the first to stop the
link or granite era base yeah but it's
so much break in like here we go we're
gonna Siegfried versus as a little
matchup this is pretty much I feel like
it's it's pretty wildly agreed upon this
is the number one and two cartoon again
it's not just like the level of the
characters level if the skill we're
gonna see through right the two
incredibly talented players here we'd go
game of one of link boys versus blue god
I'm blue God's gonna start on an
almighty and of course shutting that
down with a B slide on the base hold
right now gonna do the same there got
the low big damage already below half
house
okay punish on itself
here we go over the real unguent but not
today
don't there AGA whips and that guy
couldn't see got police on him probably
trying to duck get away from me I cannot
lose
Oh talks under a narrative that's what
we're talking about baby blue God with
always the gods like punished just the
grab and goes pulled up want to hold
this for me baby girl here you go back
just like that oh so clean digging
around one another Chuck right there on
the throw blue God has been doing really
strong on this which doesn't it's gonna
be able to break that through you know
you didn't duck that one but he did
block that on the doctor they got the
lethal hit here as well don't sit out he
actually just told him to sit out go get
get get wrong yeah why me you know I'm
incidentally earlier said actually was
regarded she was talking about yeah I'm
just always gonna go mid enjoy until
like a very end and that's when you see
me and he's like exactly that it just
went bit like six I very scary position
here for blinkers okay black me AJ the
three aim just by itself
all three eight four got him at the
legend even Frederick at me but I wonder
if because he was at the ledge when he
had three or he wasn't able to go
anywhere negative 12
here we go oh he got ya he immediately
went to beyblade after that knockdown
caught him gonna get magical ride you
going on over there honey not today
get down I mean this is a sick freak
magic card for right this time that's
right a DA comes out you have a d6 it's
done that's one of the coolest things I
get to see about high-level caliber is
that they're always trying to heads up
beat somebody into pressing a button so
they run around them like and just try
to catch it's getting a little bit too
antsy you know here we go oh oh baby
let's go yeah but no punish him I mean
like the thing is that's great for link
cords because of how much card damage it
does he however is in dark legacy state
right now no no it's not about the
bubble he cannot lose already jumps over
and he actually got him I actually did
that
anyhow thought it's Lauren I straight up
the dock okay got below there twice the
power get away from me I'm naked as well
I got power-ups for day baby let's go
yeah gonna have to do with this 50/50
right here possibly no he backs off and
the aga actually beats beyblade
oh yeah just go set up rather than doing
anything else the muscle buster look how
much extra damage he did by forgoing the
damage that he would have guaranteed
and just going further McLoughlin
absolutely and safer here we go get me
some of this orange in here oh I cannot
lose oh that's a big whip and that's a
big punish right there glucose was the
first game when it looked like it was
tire strength it just took one whip for
me I simply would have blocked it well
you know here we go to our next match of
them linkers taking Game one will boost
bring it back so given to the people who
go match that rematch fun theme stage
new me let's get it already pushing to
the ledge right there he's able to block
solo but oh my goodness no actual punish
on that and then ends up getting hit by
another low he tucks fifth row though a
lot of damage on him so far even slide
while just literally out of range of
that another no like all the muscle
busted a rocket out just like that to be
rounds one you saw him much damage blue
rot hatorah Julian how far ahead link
ours was until he's not big chillin oh
not today link boys putting up that
pressure for days I think he's actually
only going to low and that's situation
goes so far I think he's holding on to
the mid as long as you can alright good
brushstroke the crowd is screaming about
stuff I've no idea what they're saying
yeah you know we got the noise
cancelling headphone so we can't really
see with the full charges coming out for
blue boy you ever get the knock down
right here and he doesn't mix up city
but wow yeah it's about a place put
another watch she didn't have any fear
no remorse about getting it out of a
blade nothing dark plate you see his act
as for a for comes off Oh get away from
baby
alright good fresh ground oh there it is
finally a mid oh he's a buddy so he got
him he caught him breathing and that's
what link horse talks about excelling at
he was saying I know your rhythm I'm
gonna press the button before you do so
you get counter hit that was the exact
situation
Leigh boys lookin mighty faces here at
that point Tim blue gotta bring it back
though he needs this soul charges tries
to get them an advantage now he's so
afraid in that situation horses up
before him jumping with the five eggs
right there here comes almighty beyblade
okay Oh probably stepping oh no wow he's
go to the graph stayin alive all day
baby let's go uh-uh right now he's about
to have to par though on the side of the
coin there it is oh yeah you've really
wanted that back so sadly we will turn
around just in time for linkers coming
out yeah forcing this whole chart he had
just gotten that me Teresa's knee to but
the AJ he's putting up that pressure he
doesn't want to get a chance to be in
these 50/50 situation and then gonna get
the see he's got another bar to work
with these in Dark Legacy can't ring out
oh yeah forgot [ __ ] it's fine here we
go oh okay
never got 101 agreed for games then on
the final machinist Knight who won't be
stayin alive in this tournament and who
will be eliminated here at Soul Calibur
world invitationals my heart was racing
so fast I can't even remember what moves
do a new life alert button quick yeah
the throw the throw brake was super
super clutch like they're from bling
cars but he was in sorts and so he was
able to get the five a be finishing it
off right there
want or want right now I think they hit
random stage on that one you know we
change the scenery yep here we go in oh
and it's at the end of the game
basically so baby girl no not to take it
off I am very surprised that he broke
back because he was up at the wall
flapjacking on the board might have lost
five or something but I guess he was
ready for it he got the launch while you
were trying to AV slide take challenging
oh and there's the launch that's gonna
do it
step one somebody's told you no to serve
these Nikes right here he's gonna be put
in the middle of the st. what I mean you
know he's got that bar coming out and
they're incredibly dominant that round
there's nothing else to say about it he
was just having the momentum on his side
putting stance with this one the throw
gets broken it again leaks or leak or
super strong approach okay no nevermind
that damage is adding up brother look at
that 50% HP already gone almighty stance
now comes the throw Oh talks under the
age incredible talk right there good
presence of - we got to butter the heat
store we're gonna have it life that was
it there's the lethal hit right into the
feed you gonna let it rip there's so
much fire like my mixtape let's go here
we go Kendall it was close it out though
what an excellent sidestep right there
if you tried to go over the mix up right
there the air is the icon I'll lose
forcing this whole tries out so much car
damage and chip damage on him from that
and yeah he's trying to knock me bleed
right here because he's looking for
exactly that's not the guy he's near the
wall he is big just leave me the walls
like guaranteed follow-up just like that
blue got glut check it out and now the
tables have turned blue God on match
point Oliver link horse running with two
bars right now blue cod with a yellow
flashing car capes
you can hold my hand like that baby girl
jumps it comer on my hand
oh what a step right there you tried to
get the lethal hip into it that's a
different website I put it again
Symphony finishing it off right there
look God is so beautiful each time let's
give a shout out to Lake wheeler it will
give a round of applause for link guards
yeah making it so far it's link or is
one of the better players in the u.s.
obviously no longer started in Soul
Calibur 5 now here unfortunately going
to be taking the 4th place but I mean
it's the 4th place and quite possibly
the most active bracket possible it is
because it is the world Invitational so
this is the talent